know is that she is quite aggressive
cool
yeah and i've always viewed her as much
more dangerous with white than with
black so okay we do see a king's pawn
opening a sicilian defense
all right tonight comes out we see an
open sicilian
magnus he's been relying on the sicilian
a lot more in the last few years
and okay it's going to transpose to one
of my favorite openings the c3 sicilian
the aleppin uh variation and uh white
just wants to build a pawn center magnus
now
offering a trade in the center we do see
some very quick moves i'm surprised by
that last one by magnus um against me in
blitz he always recaptured there with
the queen in the center bringing his
queen out early but uh no yeah very
solid by black uh since he tries to
avoid kind of possible draw options and
now the game moved to
terrace defense in french opening kind
of a replacement and black is
gonna
suffer a little bit with isolated pawn
but of course magnus is hoping to get
the direct initiative and delivering the
pieces to the center so let's let's see
how it's going yep this variation
regarded as very very solid for black
but
from my experience as you mentioned you
have any
often black tries to get active but it
can be hard if white just stays solid
just blocks in the center and
we might just see
magnus try to strategically outplay
outplay kostenik later in the game
okay it's surprising that he's thinking
right now black's knight normally comes
out in front of the black king black's
king needs to run away to safety as
quickly as possible there is an open
line towards that king so
okay yeah he might consider some uh like
captures on d4 first and then knight g7
but uh i think he's already
uh in a way to surprise uh casting and
he wants to have some fresh fresh
position okay
the risk is if you try and surprise your
opponent you could surprise yourself in
a position like this where uh it's been
played thousands and thousands of times
and uh usually black's plans are quite
well known if magnus wants to
maybe continue surprising her and
freestyle a bit he will be taking some
risks in the process
i'm expecting to see black's night move
the black knight that hasn't left its
start square yet
and then uh yeah we'll see how familiar
kusteniak is with the plans
um i'm very surprised i think kostenik
will be looking at this position
especially now magnus is still thinking
and she'll be feeling a bit more
confident yeah um i have to say maybe it
was magnus who was surprised
uh you know with with her choice of
playing she plays this all the time
plays it all the time regularly the c3
sicilian i remember i played her in 2008
okay in a challenge match with giants
remember you played her in 2003 yes
we were playing with giant chess pieces
that's mostly why i remember them as a
kid i was like oh these pieces are
nearly as big as me but uh there she was
employing uh this opening already so
nearly 20 years ago yeah yeah and
like a through back to to that time she
was working with
um evgeny swechenko famous grandmaster
who actually claimed that this c3 c3
sicilian is winning for white and so
just uh get it so we we are wrong with
magnus choice yeah yeah so magnus did
bring his knight out but not to the
usual square actually black's knight
normally parks itself in front of the
black king in order to prevent any
checks so magnus he's opening himself up
to some possible checks right now for
example from the white rook white's rook
could just step across one square and
hit the black king that would cause
maybe a bit of discomfort but uh this is
still relatively well known i think as
you have can you said it it can
transpose from a different opening the
french defense
and the ideas are very similar there but
i have to say um your night move putting
the night in front of the king
way more popular there's been 956 games
in that one in this night move only 36
games and uh top one daniel dubov
okay so daniel dubois has been employing
yeah
okay a friend of magnus carlsen's uh
helper of magnus carlsen's
but it's surprising to see magnus think
for two minutes and then play a move
um that is a bit rare maybe he's aware
that
uh daniel dubov has played it before and
we just see a porn trade there nothing
too much changed yeah perhaps he was
simply trying to memorize
what is in his notes or kind of simply
remembering the games
against danielle bliss games that they
played so it
every every everything could happen
about the magnus choice and
i think that uh he would blitz out some
some next moves especially in case of a
check on e file
and he checked black wool block by
bringing his light squared bishop out i
guess
and uh the game would go on there are
some lines where white can even get
greedy and snatch a porn but we might
show those later if they do arise black
central porn you have getting mentioned
it's isolated it's weak potentially but
it does control some squares and black
pieces at least are likely to become
quite active
so okay holidays but promising for and
yeah both players taking some time to
think already in the beginning of this
game now we're talking about uh russian
chess
obviously a lot of fantastic male
players you have guinea but for female
players how what is the state
for chess when it comes to the female
players is it blooming there as well are
they feeling supportive or you know yeah
for sure
russian chess federation supports
all kind of ambitions to get the crowns
back to russia so i i think uh
russian female players also have uh
a lot of support i mean from uh from the
system let's call it russian chess
system and alexandra
some time ago she she claimed that
russian parliament
and some
kind of sport committees don't follow
her successes but yeah it was a big big
article on internet but beside that i i
think that russian chess federation
especially if we compare to the period
let's say uh 20 years ago uh really
improved
their
the support
also the financial support to the top
players
fantastic yeah women as well women as
well yeah yeah have you been impressed
by her recently of getting she's had a
great year actually winning the world
cup winning the world's uh the world
rapid championship for women
um because she's maybe slightly older
than some of her rivals now but she's
still right there at the top and she has
been for
10 20 years now yeah true i
i played many games against alexandra
like face to face in person and i have
to admit that the main quality of her is
kind of fighting spirit she's very very
tough we're not talking about the like
chess parts of understanding but uh
every move move by move she accepts as
the kind of uh fight kind of uh approach
to beat the opponent she's real
sportsman and of course in female chess
it's very very special like to be
capable with a kind of
pressure
and now she challenges the men's side
and it's very special for her to see how
she keeps this
long distance tournament in rabbits
fantastic and we do have a few moves
from both of them actually yeah and uh a
big big decision by magnus carson ivanka
yeah he's been played before he's about
to sacrifice the pawn
actually has been played but not too
many i mean the person who actually
deviated from the lions of theory it's
actually alexandra it was much more
standard to give a check to the king
instead she moved her knight to the
center and yep this pawn sacrifice
is uh actually been played before and it
looks like it might be slightly better
for black okay better for black wow so
um with that in mind because tenuk has
avoided grabbing a pawn in this position
the knight now is attacked twice white
could actually capture either way with
the knight or with the bishop but just
for example uh we would see white go up
a pawn here attacking the queen as well
say the queen moves the white knight
steps back white would be upper pawn but
as ivanka mentioned black maybe is doing
pretty well here just because the pieces
will be so active the bishop can come
out hitting the white rook the rooks
have easy access to nice lines and the
black knight can centralize itself at
some point black has just fantastic
activity great compensation for the pawn
so
i'm slightly surprised by this but she's
just developed a piece not choosing to
challenge magnus's idea just bringing
the bishop out supporting the knight in
the center on the outpost blocking this
isolated pawn and she's just saying okay
she wants to be solid instead but the
reason i'm surprised is because now
magnus at the very least can just bring
his queen out okay he brings it in a
different way but uh he brings the queen
out and now there's no issue at all with
black's position if anything black is
doing pretty well because there are
threats for example of the knight
jumping forward and then the queen
attacking the white king side this is
already looking pretty pleasant for
black
and yeah yeah i think also potentially
there is the opportunity to play a6
bishop a7 bishop b8 that's very
very famous trick for the isolated pawn
like to get the battery we call it
battery on the long diagonal and giving
the checkmate also on h2
so if if
if we have one minute to return back i'm
also
really surprised about the knight d4
move
since uh
like russian chess school says when
you're playing against the isolated pawn
you have to trade the dark squared
bishops especially so it was the
opportunity to give the czech rookie one
to develop the bishop bishop p3 knight
on f3 uh is pretty stable so you can
play h3 and try to control the dark
squares so knight d4 is a little bit uh
going against the classical chess
education because you have still really
undeveloped flank
yeah and actually you called it you're
getting magnus is going for a very
similar plan to the one you mentioned
if we catch up with the game position
he's just dropped his bishop back one
square so he's hinting that he already
wants to drop it back again and create
this threat of a checkmate and white's
king actually lacks defenders around it
yeah so not easy to defend those light
squares and so dark squares and one
thing that is going to be really
apparent is that white pushed the tiny
pawn next to the king now that tiny pawn
can actually be a hook for the black
pieces to come in and open up the king
so it doesn't really give the i mean
okay it's the plan with it to give the
king lift that you always talk about
that but it can actually backfire
definitely can black backfire because
every time alexandra will try to protect
those dark squares that actually might
involve pushing a pawn forward and she
might actually want to take that pawn
back and there you can see david
highlighting you know how that pawn and
that's sitting there on the h3 square
can be a tiny bit vulnerable actually
it's going to be not tiny bit vulnerable
it's going to be really really soft ah
so a big threat already in the position
just dropping back with the bishop and
lining up this battery and uh yeah
alexandra already has to face some
threats yeah she has to really be
careful about what she does here
difficult questions to answer and
potentially a lot of action for magnus
and uh talking about action we also love
it when you at home
join in the action that they can see a
developing move and we love it when
you're part of the fun and the
excitement and we would definitely like
you to join in the conversation and can
you please do that by tweeting us using
the hashtag chesschamps and we
especially love it when you send us your
selfies
remember get your phone in landscape and
take a picture and we will feature them
on the show definitely yeah some people
around the world probably having
breakfast right now maybe over in the
u.s someone is you know late at night in
china or in australia
so much fun to see what you all are
doing when you're watching the show and
following these fantastic chess players
another move yep another move so white
did bring a night out
develop that piece maybe the idea from
alexandra was to bring that knight over
to defend her king on the next move but
magnus's sense the opportunity to trade
a set of pieces in the center at least
one set of minor pieces and now white is
going to get an isolated pawn as well as
black in the middle magnus simply wants
to grab the pawn in case like very
logical bishop takes d4 he takes back on
d4 and there is a double thread of queen
b6
so
magnus thinks if if pawn is there there
is some some good opportunities in the
in the continuation of the game
and basically it forces white to take
with a c pawn and then the bishop on e3
is uh i'm sorry to say really awful and
kind of development for white
been
really unsuccessful in this game
can she just simply smile and go well
you know the opening didn't really work
out for me and then regroup
you know fix them
fix some some of those weaknesses yeah
in her defense the pawn structure is
pretty much symmetrical so if she can
exchange some pieces if she can survive
the next 10 15 moves then she'll
probably be doing okay but uh yeah just
this one bad piece makes her position
slightly inferior it feels like and i
agree with you forgetting i'm slightly
surprised the evaluation bar says 0.0
because black is the one having the fun
this bishop is so much better than this
bishop
exactly let's compare all the pieces
light square bishop also better for
black knight is better for black there
are more opportunities of course for
machine it's nothing like computer says
okay there is a symmetry no weaknesses
basically we can guard the the one and
we are enjoying but time runs this is
rapid and uh it's uh really really tough
to take the concrete solutions because
uh threats are coming yeah still this
idea is in the air of trying to break
through on this diagonal and that might
cause some concessions from white yes
and i really do like magnus's last move
because it not only developed a piece
but also when the knight comes to the
square that alexandra's placed it on the
bishop can actually centralize itself
and uh start asking some questions like
okay you're defending the king for now
yeah i i think uh alexandra wants to
park her knight in the center of the
board as well just to kind of plug some
holes just to put it on an active square
at least having one strong piece uh
strong centralized piece but yeah it
looks like maybe black's position is
just slightly easier to handle and
magnus you can tell by the speed of his
moves he's just developing pieces he
brought this bishop out now he's brought
his rook to an open line he's just
improving easily while alexandra still
has some questions to answer well you
said she's an aggressive player has she
is she over pushing a little bit is she
too aggressive in this game
no she's not i i think
she clearly like feels comfortable at
the moment for the reason uh there are
no like direct threats
so she's uh she was trying to push to
surprise magnus in the opening but now
she clearly realizes that there is
nothing in the position she tries to
change maybe potentially she is ready
for a little bit worse position but it's
uh
it's long
long game to be played yep so
she uh
she really like feels comfortable and
i'm not 100 sure that magnus feels
comfortable in this position because he
needs to create something extraordinary
to get the play yes pieces are good but
what's next yeah i think if magnus was
playing maybe one of his biggest rivals
another 27 2800 player he'd be very
happy with black you'd think okay i've
more than equalized my position is maybe
slightly better and from here i can
slowly press the advantage no risk but
against someone like alexandre who he
probably wants to beat um yeah he will
need to
um maybe change his mindset and um
alexandra she's gone the opposite of uh
aggressive with her last move just
trying to trade a set of bishops she's
just trying to lock things down try to
eliminate and just try and liquidate the
position if she can get the bishops off
the board knights off the board it will
just fizzle out this position towards
the draw so solid play from alexandra
but magnus needs to create something as
you mentioned yeah let's try to guess
some moves i i think the bishop would be
placed on e4
and
then magnus would play rook e8 and
potentially he thinks to play bishop c7
and knight d7 kind of keep control over
over the center
and uh he he would not change the the
pieces like simply changing the pieces
uh he will try to force
alexandra to take critical solutions
okay 94 yeah almost there very similar
yeah very similar idea and the reason
you mention uh this move as well is
because if alexandra wants to trade
pieces which she probably does at some
point then this would at least allow
magnus to imbalance the position and um
often when you're trying to win against
an opponent who just wants to be solid
in balancing things changing the pawn
structure is one of the ways to do that
and now black has a nice central square
and outpost which white will never
challenge and um yeah decent chances
long term so instead magnus has gone for
a similar idea planting his night in the
middle of the wood now white will never
ever take this knight because that would
give black the bishop pair and allow
black to change the pawn structure
favorably
but instead kostani brings her queen out
what do you think of this move because
it kind of goes against my little rules
you know that the queen should always be
within touching distance of her king
especially when there's the makings of
an attack
tr true and uh looks like black gonna
play on the king's side right yeah and
then you move the queen on the queen's
side so basically like uh
ignoring all possible threats uh of
course there is no queen g6 move at the
moment but i i suppose it might be some
tricks already with bishop takes h3 then
check queen h5 attacking the king round
uh of course it's easy to understand
queen bit remove because uh alexander
consolidating the pieces now the rooks
are connected she wants to play rook ac1
and start trading everything on the c
file uh however queen is too far and i'm
pretty sure magnus is
taking a look on bishop takes h3 maybe
even right now because there is the rook
coming on the sixth rank so uh king king
of white is very very weak so we're
really dangerous yeah this would uh
definitely cross magnus's mind and
you're right he's probably calculating
this this is a nasty check and if the
king moves to the side the queen can
start attacking um some of these pawns
loose pieces and just to show your idea
as well you're getting just this rook
can swing across to join the attack as
well and we know that magnus is a fan of
the old rook lift yeah he loves these
ideas
i've commentated with him on the
candidates tournament in every single
position that there was a rook lift
available he would want to play it he
would say okay let's just show this
let's show it on the board and this rook
coming across that might be a key idea
for later so um yeah this one's
definitely in the air i'm not 100 sure
it works right now
but magnus will try and line it up and
okay slightly surprising he's chosen to
move this rook to the e file uh possibly
just trying to avoid some trades if he'd
moved his other rook which is maybe the
more natural move then this would have
allowed white to challenge some rooks
and pieces would disappear the advantage
would disappear as well so magnus
maybe there is a little little trick
behind the move like knight g3 some kind
of discovered jumps because the bishop
on the tree is hanging so he tries to
pointing out that the e file is uh also
very challenging for white and
potentially he was he simply tries to
keep the game going uh avoiding all
possible exchanges on the c file
very interesting move why were you
surprised david you said a little bit
surprising yeah it's just because the
other rook if you talk to it now if you
ask it how it's doing it's not happy
it's been boxed in by its other rook so
this rook normally wants to be the one
using this square but magnus just wanted
to avoid any trades and the other reason
i'm surprised is because it's just not
human instinct to give up access to an
open file with europe especially because
black had just moved his rook a couple
of turns ago and then moved it again for
a second time but then again there are
specific ideas behind it to justify that
move and now look at the central tension
look at the pattern of these pieces
these nights bit of symmetry there pawns
symmetrically yeah i have to say david i
really don't like what's just happened
now because i think alexandra was root
too hasty to put her knight in the
middle of the board look good but magnus
has kicked it back and once the knight
retreats
then black can start doing this idea of
actually start asking some questions on
the dark squares he simply again gained
the tempo for for something else but uh
alexandre is um
yeah look at this magnus is going on the
attack he's not holding back anymore
he's trying to launch a pawn storm on
this king side um he's gonna maybe push
this pawn forward next push this pawn
forward dislodge the white knight get
rid of white's best defender and uh the
attack is brewing
yeah
as you guys said he's just been given
this move for free alexandra wasted two
moves with her knight and that was the
signal for magnus to attack i think this
was maybe his plan anyway and uh
computers still not impressed but in
human terms this is scary right yeah and
marching forward you can uh easily
realize how the sitting position of
alexander has just changed immediately
after this f6 and g5 from the relaxed uh
let's say
relaxed position using the chair
comfortable yeah and uh now she's uh
full in the game she understands that
like a couple of moves are gone
look at this it continues upon pushing
forward again is this uncomfortable now
for alexandra
to actually get those pawns just this is
not you basically this is terrifying
stuff kaya
no one wants this kind of situation
because have a look at how many pieces
there are circling around the white king
there's the queen that is pointing that
direction there's a knight that's right
in in the half of alexandria then
there's a light squared bishop that is
primed to maybe even sacrifice itself
and let's not forget that black is now
threatening to push a pawn forward as
well and
and it doesn't even stop there because
you see that dark squared bishop that is
not doing that much well it can actually
move one square backwards and suddenly
it will be assisting the queen so
yeah maybe there's a way for white to
defend against this magnus was gesturing
and the bar is
on the right side here
yeah
i'm surprised i don't know about you
guys but uh about the computer
evaluation here i don't trust it
probably the computer says okay there's
a way to defend and once you've defended
then black's just weakened himself or
there's nothing too much to worry about
at least but um yeah for me as a human i
would be thinking okay black has made
progress black has actually done
something active
white has made some moves but they're
not necessarily improving the position
and the momentum at least is on black
side it's easier to play the plans i
mean can we defend with the white pieces
because black side what is very simple
we just push the pawn forward and then
maybe like uh this moment is pretty
critical for alexandra pawns are rolling
uh she can get in troubles and she has
to decide something with knight on f3 as
far as we see she played 92 she uh
continues the idea like trading the
pieces but it was like final warning
call for her uh g4 g3 mate g4 opening
file mate
and uh yeah knight d2 was predictable
and i guess that that the move is to
hide the knight on a fan uh at least try
to stabilize a little bit uh the
king's safety and preparing f3 the kick
off of magnus knight yeah maybe this is
the point i've uh quite funny i i saw
some games not that long ago where alpha
zero was stepping up with the king and
in fact it was going up to the sixth row
and the whole idea was actually to just
make sure that the rooks could actually
go all the way to the right side once
those lines are open and uh okay i think
okay oh we see some trades trades yeah
and then before very surprising no yeah
um you're surprised that black didn't
just take the bishop pair and continue
um
i guess that would have involved a
change in pawn structure magnus just
wants to
uh control everything avoid any possible
counter play and castenia is struggling
for any ideas she's pushed her a pawn
forward okay it wants to push forward
and destabilize the black bishop but
maybe the black bishop wants to move
anyway over the next couple of turns
magnus just securing his king securing
the seventh rank that white maybe wanted
to enter on later with some actual
queensland but this solution bishop
takes c4 and trading trading all pieces
only four is really really scary because
uh white is losing all potential to play
for kind of advantage or kind of
counterplay now they have a very bad
bishop on e3 versus good bishop good
uh rival on b6 yeah that's a one-way
traffic now yeah and so magnus can do
whatever he wants uh basically having in
mind their pleasant end game as well
yeah and this is one thing i think for
all viewers at home it can be human
instinctive especially if you're playing
a higher rated player to just try and
exchange pieces
as a human you think okay i'm guiding
the game towards a draw and guiding it
towards safety but if you're worsening
your position by making those exchanges
if you're spending the time making those
exchanges and you're left with bad
pieces like white's bishop here is
basically just doing the job of a pawn
then
yeah exchanges don't necessarily save
you and the evaluation bar now finally
seeing that black's position is just
very very pleasant there's still this
idea of black's bishop dropping back
lining up with the black queen and
trying to enter near the white king and
this one is
it's looking very very bad for white now
and i have to say i would really love to
give a round of applause to black's last
move because you know i don't think i
would have necessarily played it but
first magnus takes the chance to just
secure his king out david says and also
there's still the rook is primed for
aggressive notions it can still go on to
the open lines it can even support the
dark squared bishop and still there is
all those there are all those threats on
the board of uh just pushing those pawns
forward yeah i think magnus will play
for the attack here some viewers at home
might be wondering why can't black get
greedy just snatch off white central
pawn and probably the answer is white i
mean that is possible black can just go
upon up if he wants but why bother and
maybe there is a trick behind after
exchanging bishops there is queen e3
pointing out that one on a7 is also
hanging possibly so
i don't think magnus will even consider
grabbing in the center there's no need
to i don't think any any grandmaster
would consider grabbing honey for so we
all are playing for a mate mate is the
most interesting thing in chess yes i
agree that's the end of the game and
talking of checkmate magnus is lining up
an attack against the white king look at
that black queen and the black bishop
they're on an open diagonal that black
queen i mean how are you going to stop
it entering yeah well steny says she
doesn't even want to stop it entering
maybe there was no way to do that yeah i
mean her king is going to go on an epic
journey i'm not sure it's going to
survive though
well those white rooks looks quite nice
though on the same line they're on the
same line but the problem is that
they're not defending the king
and that is the primary
problem with white's position and
the king is going to have to find some
solace in the middle of the board
notoriously not the safest place and
i've got to interrupt as well because i
think black can just win on the spot
black can give a check the king moves
black can give another check okay i
thought black could just give another
check the white king moves and then
black could just grab white's rook there
was a pin on the e file and
magnus would just have won a rook for
free but okay he's trying to break
through if that white bishop now moves
then black's queen will just come down
one square and that's going to be
checkmate the white king is trapped so
white's bishop is all that stands
between
magnus and chatmate now yeah alexander
clearly blundered the rook but i think
bishop four is also enough actually when
you're concentrated on attack you can't
forget about some other pieces on board
yeah so like at the moment you're
threatening uh
sacrifice on the tree of exchange or
bishop takes e3 but uh i mean queen
check uh everything happening around and
uh alexander is also three minutes down
in time i i don't think that the
position is uh possible to be defended
yeah as you mentioned this bishop is the
only thing holding things together and
it's not going to survive for too long
this check is going to be the deadly one
just to show the other idea at home that
i mentioned this check would have won
the game immediately you can actually
take this rook
using a pin on this line meaning white's
bishop cannot recapture the black queen
this would have been deadly but magnus's
idea good enough as well and bishop
takes bishop now that is simply
checkmate the king has no more escape
squares and what else is there to do
simply the queen will give check next or
the rook will come across white has no
counter play at all
and even if you play queen takes pawn
now we would i mean there's plenty of
ways to win this but at the very least i
think black could give a check and just
take this pawn now this
indirect threat against white's queen
this bishop now is doomed and this is
just game over
um yeah white can try and attack the
black king but it's just too slow you
take too long whereas white's king is
going to get checkmated over the next
couple of moves
so did
alexandra sort of over push a little bit
here get unlucky in the opening or can
we sort of say that magnus is starting
to look like himself again after a bad
finish to yesterday's uh rounds oh it it
looked very easy for magus
in this game he didn't make anything
special he just developed the pieces
maybe rook c2e8 when he had chosen the
plan of
uh advancing the pawns rolling the pawns
on the king's side was a kind of special
champions solution
at least
to complicate the white's decisions in
in continuation of the game but beside
that
magnus just made the ordinary moves
and yeah you can you can see alexandra
already understood everything she's
partially smiling as far as i can see uh
so
no
i i think in kind of
more decisive games let's let's call
like this we will see if magnus is back
or not all right well we have to applaud
alexandra of course she is the lowest
ranked player in the tournament but
taking on the challenge it must be a
little bit scary with these top top top
grand masters
yeah no doubt i mean because at the back
of your mind if you're so much lower
rated than everyone else then you do
think oh you know how am i going to
actually cope with uh being hard work on
the board and being the moving target
for everyone to try to catch um but then
again
it's a lesson yeah this is the thing and
so all credit for her she's here and
she's fighting as hard as she can and
and i think this was an unfortunate game
you know i think she got a bit confused
out of the opening and uh made some
inaccuracies but magnus perfect very
logical chess is making it look easy and
and is it still easy for magnus or can
stuff still happen in this game yeah
it's it feels like he's done the hard
work white's king is just too much of a
target black's queen is just too active
you can never let an opponent's queen
that knew your king and hope to survive
so i think magnus has done the hard work
a little bit of calculation maybe still
needed but
he's got plenty of time on the clocks
more than seven minutes and um even
suffering with kovid as we mentioned i
think magnus is going to finish off this
game
pretty smoothly it's just hard to find a
move here for white which doesn't allow
checkmate or doesn't allow huge material
losses so
um magnus just putting his head in his
hands but he's got this game wrapped up
and
okay because then it does try and grab
the pawn as we showed black gives a
check and black did capture a pawn and
just there's an unstoppable threat in
the position pretty much rook takes
bishop next move black's rook taking the
white bishop with check will actually
unleash a discovered check uh discovered
attack sorry against white's queen as
well the queen's they're on the same
diagonal and white's queen at the very
least is gonna fall and there is no
square for the king to escape from the
discover check yeah because
in case of king d2 let's say pinning
winning the black's queen back but then
bishop takes e3 not true this time yeah
bishop takes also means but yeah
i think everything wins here in this
position uh for magnus white's bishop is
simply falling on the next move uh black
would capture it with his bishop or rook
and that's just came over and okay it
does run away with her king
um again plenty of winning moves here
but just okay i was going to say either
bishop takes bishop or a check first and
this is very effective magnus wins the
white bishop and
okay because then he resigns a bishop
down in a hopeless position all right
that is a very nice win for magnus
carlsen in
game one